[Music]
the state of free speech on college
campuses is uh normal loser and
what I mean by that is very very
bad
hi my name is Greg lukianov and I'm the
president and CEO of the foundation for
individual rights and expression and the
co-author of cancelling of the American
mind a book I wrote with my friend Ricky
schlot the situation for free speech on
on college campuses has been dire for a
long time we we can't find another
period uh since the law was established
protecting campus free speech and uh
campus academic freedom between 1957 and
1973 um in which you know this many
professors have been targeted or or or
fired for that
[Music]
matter
we're talking about twice that number
for cancel culture which we designate as
beginning in 2014 so in a very real
sense you're talking about a situation
that is worse um that it was in in one
of the most famous bad periods for
academic freedom but the difference is
back during the the second Red Scare
everyone knew there was a problem um so
much so that there was a massive study
you know taking place like at the time
pointing out like how bad it had
actually gotten on campus whereas the
weird thing with cancel culture you know
is that people are still uh you know uh
ideologues are still actually claiming
this isn't even happening or some kind
of right-wing hoax or doesn't exist you
have a bad day but where there is some
encouraging news is um after a
particularly embarrassing um incident
that we talk about in cancelling the
American mind the shout down of fifth
Circuit Judge Kyle Duncan at my alma
moded Stanford law school racism is show
Stanford started actually taking some
efforts that looked you know like like
Steps in the right direction um for free
speech and we're happy about that but
2023 was a particularly bad year not as
much for Professor cancellations or
student cancellations but for shout
Downs um including the Stamford one but
also you know not too long before the
one at Yale law school but also like
truly scary
[Music]
ones a an incident at San Francisco
State Unity iversity where you know it
led that people assaulted Riley Riley
gains but certainly you know like they
they shouted her
down and sfsu sort of complemented The
Bravery of some of these activists and
it's like no you're enforcing the
popular will on that campus you're
taking a popular position on that campus
and you're bullying someone from talk
talking out of it there's nothing
commendable about that um so I I I
thought that 2023 was a pretty bad year
just in a different way
we've been taking some flak from the
right uh in that cancelling of the
American mind has three chapters talking
about cancel culture from the right we
have about 20 chapters talking about
ccel culture from the left um and do I
think that's appropriate absolutely I do
because uh even though we AB we
correctly point out that these problems
exist on both the right and the left we
don't try to pretend that they're of
equal proportion on the right and the
left so cancel culture is is at its wor
first at Elite higher education in the
United States which is overwhelmingly
super majority left leaning both in
terms of Administrators and
[Music]
professors the most important thing for
the moment right now and going to 2024
is people have to start thinking big
about higher education reform they have
to start thinking about experiments um
that are smaller cheaper smarter than
higher education they have to start
thinking about alternative models like
University of Austin Texas they have to
start looking at the campus Free Speech
ranking that fire does and sending their
kids to schools that do well and telling
schools that don't that we didn't even
apply to you because you did so poorly
so now is the moment when we need to
actually really be trying to fix this
problem that's been getting worse for a
very long time and that's been
particularly at a crisis mode for at
least uh 6 years
now